keeping it tight keeping it tight up
around the sides there yeah a little
tight yeah a little bit of a you got a
samurai thing going you that's a right
that's a samurai uh
no sir i don't think so i think that's a
that's when you have a good hair
hairline you go samurai that would be
yeah that's how the samurai would be i
like how you do the proper that's
happening
and when you when you when you are
somebody right you have to study bushido
which is the way of the warrior oh yeah
and you hang out you hang a sword and
you know what the official color is
because life is exact like that final
and exact there is no room for error
with a sword and then white man said
cool swords that's cool check this out
cool
and the portuguese when the portuguese
were they were very good sailors when
they got to the uh the shores of the
land of the rising sun
again
okay oh jack duck died yeah when that
happened the the you know what the do
you know what the portuguese said to the
king
they came back and they said hey real
quick suck us do not give these people
[ __ ]
gun powder
because if you give them gunpowder
they're going to [ __ ] everybody up
because they had been in a low-grade
civil war for roughly a thousand years i
mean it was basically these this is [ __ ]
you need to know that's why that's why
they were so i love it brian explains it
well that's why they were so good at
making metal because they were like
those portuguese were like wait a minute
how come this metal doesn't break and
why is it so [ __ ] sturdy and why can
it cut through something what was the
the fold
metallurgy they would fold it they would
just master sword makers
they could they would fold the steel and
i guess when you fold it i don't know
but and you keep thinking it makes sense
so this isn't what the last samurai is
about with tom cruise with the white
boys
yeah that the way of life ended because
of gunpowder
and remember when they're lighting up
the guy who just has swords yeah he's on
the bridge
because he's the last one why did why
did
yeah
why did why well it's tom cruise why
why why why would they why wouldn't they
why
yeah
why did why did knighthood remember when
you where you guys were in night in
shining armor yeah it was a whole it was
a it was a warrior class of knights
right swords way of fighting why'd that
go out of style
overnight what invention here's a little
quiz what what did they invent that
turned that thing
obsolete it was just no you couldn't use
it overnight
not guns not gun powder not guns not gun
powder it was before that cannons nope
arrows
arrows is in the area
arrows is in the area not a bow and
arrow crossbow yes crossbow yes sir the
crossbow yeah the crossbow turned that
thing into a steel coffin no dude
because it would just go right through
it
so
it was like world war one where they
didn't know that the [ __ ] there was
something called machine guns and
artillery yeah technology so they so
they got on their horses and they were
like let's charge they were like really
get kicked
that was the end of that and then it
just dude technology
speaking of situations all right
speaking of technology i've been waiting
for it i love you and me both about two
years i love the label this is batch one
that's one do i get it first bag that's
your bottle thank you bob i can't wait
to drink it oh check out the first oh
you got the second i almost want to
taste one little a little bit don't
crack it open daddy right
yeah i know guys can get more huh i know
a guy can get more
i'd like to i know a guy gets another
i'd like to send some of these to our
boy eric because he i know bro what did
he do
is that food he's one of us he's one of
us he's none of us he's so funny did you
meet his boy augusto who runs this show
with him yeah yeah those [ __ ] dudes i
would i would come back for my show uh
my hotel was they stay open yeah they
stay open
i'd walk by and he'd have a spread the
best with all the just ready for you
what and that wine and then did they get
the the steak for you yeah they did bro
they take that wagu number nine where
they where he personally rubs do you
know the name of the restaurant it's
called virgina virginia on fifth street
if you model you're in naples you got to
go there you got to go there it's so
[ __ ] nice this i was so i was going
to squad with i was trying how funny is
he though the best
he's the best he's the best shout out to
louise this is where this is three in
the morning luis is so high he can
barely hold his hand i know look at him
louise is so high he can't keep his head
up that's dennis who manages the [ __ ]
hook i had a blast great weekend and
here i'm i'm bragging about looking the
same age as everybody it was a silly
thing but we had such a blast
how great is he listen just turn it off
you don't have to otherwise you have to
watch the whole thing it's too easy okay
eric's great though eric is any fun eric
how new york is there he's [ __ ]
hitler i kept going get less new york
well he's he's sicilian you might as
well get a [ __ ] yankees tattoo on
your neck
new york sicilian and oh my god
you paid for it
dude i kept trying to pay dude i tried
to give them cash they would everything
i would tip the weight and it's so
expensive every night so i mean every
night but he wouldn't let me pay for it
he was opening up cask 23. that's a
stags lead that's so expensive it's cash
23. like you buy that in the restaurant
you're spending 500 bucks on a bottle
yeah isn't he the best
he's the reason
he's the reason i just keep doing naples
[ __ ] up the rest of him he made my
weekend
thank you you're welcome i was there
until three in the morning so are we
every every night in the morning how do
you [ __ ] chilling and eating great food
i mean i didn't sleep well because
you're not a watch guy he's a big watch
guy so he knows watches so we're talking
watches so it's funny to say that
because i saw the watch he had a polar
rolex a polaris polar it's a white face
okay
maybe a daytona
not to be racist but it was white face
and i i really like that watch this
it's like a it's like a nine grand i
don't know how much
way more in nine grams okay so
if he has a white daytona no he didn't
have to explore look up a white face
daytona did it have three uh uh dials on
it i'm not sure but i liked it very much
and it's the kind of watch that felt
good on my way with that is that one on
the far left i assume it was a little
bit different was it because that that's
a [ __ ] watch 40 grand i know oh
yeah and you can't walk you can't walk
they're like ferrari you can't walk in
rolex and buy those you can't no so what
do you like you have to you have to be
somebody like allocations or you got to
know somebody like you can't just walk
in it's a beast this is exciting is that
the watch that little baby got duped on
uh no not that no no listen i will go
back to naples just for this just right
here yeah me too i had so much fun and
it was the first time in a long time i i
had a group of people with me and we
were just hanging yeah and being idiots
and white and no no
no no they were they were i thought we
were reviving him there were hispanic
people there too yeah louise well your
opener what
well he counts for seven
he counts for seven minutes from
nicaragua bro oh he is yeah bro that
picture he told us that is he a comic
uh he is a or he works there he works
there no that's a good story right there
on the the smaller guy right there right
oh he runs that place with eric oh i
remember him yeah he's a good dude all
right here now louis looks
louis louise louise luis is so high
there he can't keep his head up i love
it you guys smoked the devil's lettuce i
didn't i didn't i did i drink red wine
which gives me energy you give me red
wine and good food came on at three in
the morning i'll go around the [ __ ]
correct dude we so our boy um
uh jason from uh we did the tough mudder
with him the dime piece she like bodied
up he lives in dallas he came he owned
some like thc like weed gummies yeah
called alpha something he gave them to
me he goes you smoke weed i go i really
don't but my guys do so i'll give to
them he goes
literally he goes i eat how he like
smoke with your day i eat half this i'm
[ __ ] floored he's like tell your guys
take it easy they look like candy though
i wanted to eat them all night yeah it
looks so good
that'll get you so high it'll [ __ ] but
mark took one and mark was out
yeah out oh the big line was snoring
yeah
by the way you you you had a you had
some good shows oh man couldn't win any
better i want to show unreal dude yeah i
got you look at that let my team do it
all right that's me jumping in the crowd
after the show that's a great picture
dallas is [ __ ] that's great and how
about addison this is doing that for us
he's a nutso's dude it was no and the
whole look at that the whole squad was
out there was just such a great [ __ ]
vibe and i told them so we didn't record
thursday night show was [ __ ] great my
god we probably got that one friday you
know friday early good you know there's
never bad shows in dallas but it was
good friday late fantastic so we got
both those i'm like well we kind of have
something to work with here now and i
got everybody together there's like 15
of us and i'm telling you be on the
[ __ ] ball saturday early show is
going to be the one we're going to use
like well no we can take pieces i'm like
i'm telling you saturday early is going
to be on [ __ ] real energy oh the most
excited to be there dude
they were [ __ ] nuts so you know my
sets 30 minutes
when we recorded it turned out to be 40.
because the laugh
like it was just such a beast yeah and
so you know standing though i come i i
get off stage i come back in and the
whole team's still there recording i get
on the micro i told you this is the
[ __ ] wine boys
i was fired up dude well it's admired
it's a milestone for you man yeah isn't
it yeah it was great beautiful couldn't
have been any better it was great
congratulations there he is
wait i was at him with that that's door
on the left thor yeah yeah that's jason
on the right wait who is that guy now
jason that he did the tough mudder with
us he was the one who kept trying to
electrocute me jesus christ he has holy
[ __ ]
he's an olympian dude yeah he's an
olympian yeah he's competitive yeah is
he a limb yeah he's a monster he's a
[ __ ] guy and he's handsome and
weightlifting yes
and he's 42 i think he has he has two
twins
and then he has like four kids too he's
a beast of a dad that's him that's it
look at his body
yeah he's stupid
that's ridiculous stupid diamond piece
yeah that's uh
such a good dude he's straight yeah oh
yeah dude he's big
four kids it's got such nice that's a
that that pose is sexy on the left yeah
the left one's questionable right was he
going through a phase then
i mean why i mean why wouldn't if you're
my boy and you're doing that i'm gonna
have to be like hey bro but but why
wouldn't they cast him in 300 i mean
just off that on the right i couldn't
just more in fact do do the movie over
again and cast him
yeah he's just unbelievable that's
impossible
well look at his beard and his hair
oh look at him if you look that good
he's just a good looking and just so
you'll love him it's such a good show
just such a good person sure i [ __ ]
love that he's got good style he wears
chains yeah yeah he has great fashion
which i appreciate actually the first
one first type one diabetic to win the
olympia oh he's a typhoon really first
one ever
he won the that boy yeah
oh i see he's so he's not an olympian
he's a he's a mr olympia okay olympia
but he didn't win i'm sorry no uh no he
won mr olympia yeah four times yeah four
times four times four-time winner well
but so there's different classes right
he's not in keith he phil heath's no
that that's different he's in
whatever the program is there's like
there's like he's in less gear he's in
the program he's just [ __ ] yeah
that's that's that's
there he is as a dad oh these are those
cutie kids man yeah all right let's take
a little break from chatting with the
boys because this thanksgiving be
thankful for family food and free bats
that's right draftking sportsbook the
official sportsman partner of the nfl
has a turkey day no-brainer you don't
want to miss new customers can bet just
one dollar on any thanksgiving nfl game
and win 100 and free bets if either team
scores a point all right they're gonna
score points so you're gonna win some
money if sportsbook isn't available in
your state you can still get in on the
thanksgiving nfl action make your first
deposit and you can play free
for millions dude with draftkings daily
fantasy football contest draftkings is
safe secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw whenever you want
download draftking sportsbook app right
now use promo code fighter bet just one
dollar on any thanksgiving nfl game and
win 100 in free bets if either team
scores a point that's promo code fighter
this thanksgiving at draftking
sportsbook the official sports bank
partner the nfl must be 21 or older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers are only restricting this play
see draftkings.com for details gambling
problem call 1-800 gambler
now you take kratom every day every
freaking day brian yeah you talking
about the all-natural herb related to
the coffee plant that's been used in
thailand for
ever
are you talking about the
energy booster relief stress enhances
your mood relieves aches and pains
you're talking about my favorite kratom
from superspeciosa that we're talking
about it has one ingredient we're
talking about pure kratom leaf baby
that's right and listen
kratom a little dicey out there you
never know what you're going to get with
super speciosa we got you covered man
100 satisfaction guaranteed or your
money comes back to you all right try
kratom finally try kratom chin's on it
every day i'm on every day anytime you
see me doing stand-up podcasting
whatever it is i'm on that kratom from
superspeciosa all right get 20 off your
entire order go to
getsuperleaf.com fighter use the promo
code fighter for 20 off your entire
order all right it's
dot com getsuperleaf.com fighter
yeah dallas was great i took chappelle
to the jfk shooting oh yeah drop
something drop some knowledge knowledge
on man
come on man that is it man
seeing the library to the where that
first shot is and all that i'm like
the jack ruby
that part the jack ruby is the the one
thing where i go if it's not a
conspiracy ties
well i mean
also why did he come out of nowhere
shoot him he had ties to the mob he
shoots and harvey oswald and then won't
say anything in jail no he wanted to say
something they wouldn't you know he said
they weren't better yeah he was like he
was like i'm ready to give the real
story what happened
and they went we're good anyway but dino
cats are quick you guys told me
that if i play ball with you i could
give my piece and they're like we're
good wow no one ever came to interview
and then oh that's then he died of
cancer
wait you said so you said there was a
bar
it was a speaking it was like experience
where all the the the the
the downstairs the mob the politician it
was jack ruby yeah and then jack ruby
was a nightclub owner
so what is your gun to your head what's
your assessment of the jail mafia mafia
it's not really conspiracy to me it's
like clear as day and then also like you
know buy it in even trump didn't release
the whole the whole findings the whole
warren report they didn't release that
interest they really certain things but
there's a last thing that they won't
release i think it's just mafia maybe
yeah i don't know and i'm not you know
you and i are the same i don't most
conspiracy i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
this one you're like okay
yeah yeah how do you feel about it bee
again i i think what i don't i don't put
it past some lone shooter but was the
lone shooter you get an ins you get a
guy who's not stable like lee harvey
oswald but he said he was a communist
spending time in
in cuba and russia had shot at somebody
i think before that blah blah okay fine
you you can those are the kind of people
you would use
you could place that person something
yes
and then before they can talk
easy target why would this guy jack ruby
why would he and you know what the
narrative for a while was he was so he
felt so bad for jackie kennedy that he
wanted to avenge her loss i don't buy
that
why because he was a sleazy nightclub
owner who was part of the mafia yeah and
you look at the size of new orleans
that's not how those guys are yeah dude
that's not how this but you but like you
said you said
who was the head of the mob back then
who took credit for getting him elected
apparently right republicans were
talking about all the fraud that went
into getting him the republicans that's
all they were talking about but
so
and then that was
it's different now that back then they
had it and then also what they did with
the car so when he gets shot they drive
straight to the hospital drop jfk off
and then take the card or wherever and
clean it off clean it
wash it down
reach it out range bleach it out there's
no sense which is it's just not protocol
you know you're doing a crime yeah
that's the argument it's like well why
would you guys do that and like oh we
you know we panicked we didn't want the
car to have the president's blood on
it's like yeah but it's crying
yeah and it's that we haven't seen's
missing brain everything yeah the brain
was missing you didn't tell me that the
body from the the original bullet went
through the throat yeah but why was it
on the gurney next to him very strange
yo uh a lot of it's very strange i don't
know but you know i'm not at least
harvey oswald
um was just like a regular dude in the
army like yeah he was you said to pull
that shot it wasn't an outline he was a
sharp shooter that's not i've seen he
wasn't an outlier in the military he was
very average yeah he was classified as
that but he could like okay so he could
complete a hard shot i've been i've been
i've seen that that you're shooting
straight down i was telling you guys i
don't think he's a hard trap but i think
there's 100 more than one shooter it
might have been
it might have been mm-hmm and then they
did jb's
but he had multiple he had different he
had four different bullets bullets in
him but but i even that like my thing is
if i found out there was only one
shooter it still doesn't mean that other
people weren't
behind it oh 100 percent
might have been the only shooter but it
doesn't mean that there weren't that oh
yeah didn't have the architects behind
this the jack ruby thing is the
strangest nobody's ever explained to me
why this guy they'd also be john live tv
then no it's not it's crazy yeah i was
watching imagine watching like say
you're watching the written house
trial yeah and someone just came and
shot him in the face yeah in live tv and
it's just like right there
what do they say about the what does the
warren commission say about jack ruby
what do they say about it you know ty's
crazy
he was just crazy they just put him as
chris
he said he said you already had cancer
and just want to go out on his shield
okay maybe he had a terminal diagnosis
and decided [ __ ] it but i don't
hard to hear his ties to the mafia into
the
dallas police department so strange he
was very close with him very clear
that's why they're saying when he was
there it didn't cause any red flags so
he's always hanging around there because
he he he would make sure so he owned
that nightclub cops come in he gave him
the best tables yeah they had a poker
game with politicians mafia guys uh
dallas police jack ruby like they were
all there did he have family that that
did he have family that the mafia could
have threatened or rewarded for his
behavior because again if a sam g khan
could have gone there and said listen
you do this you got to do this we'll set
your family up or or you're going to die
anyway
do us a favor we'll do you a favor
whatever it might be or by the way you
know or you owe us and if you don't do
this we're gonna have to take your phone
yeah it's all strange but it's
fascinating though huh it's possible but
brendan so like the like was there
one specific reason was there among
multiple reasons why
they would go after jfk because his
brother and jfk were cutting down hard
on the mafia they're trying to shut down
the dallas mafia scene new orleans and
new york which i thought which is weird
because the mafia got jfk elected yeah
that's that's right yeah and they were
all so they're like hold up sam gina
kind of yeah they thought he would use
him like pull up and bobby kennedy
becomes the district attorney and it's
[ __ ] just reigning he said i'm gonna
show his number one goal let's just shut
down the mafia bobby kenny died in los
angeles yeah yeah he was doing like a
press and
it's all yeah it's interesting though
man i was dropping facts yeah he was he
was driving a lot of effect it was it
was kind of crazy to see you know we got
on film for the vlog it's like when the
brandon shop jfk tore it and then i went
through all that are you give me a name
jack group and i'd go on jack ruby
there's a couple there's a couple random
people that came up and asked to bring
the questions
they knew he had something to say yeah
they did they're like i want to talk to
this and then there was a whole thing
behind us that said you could sign up
and it was like part of the conspiracy i
was like oh yeah yeah yeah i'm not doing
that right like well if you just sign
over here i'm like no i'm not there are
people there who sell like pamphlets
that guy's always there's the black guy
yeah they're uh what they say oh you
want the real yeah he's if you want the
reels right here five dollars in my
animal you want the real truth
right here yeah
it was pretty wild though that's [ __ ]
crazy what else was crazy how
people will go up to that where the x is
lay down and take a picture smile it's
like a man dies like you [ __ ] it's
like weird and mainly asian gotta be
honest asian people get there and like
where you shot in the end they're all
what kind of asians are you saying
americans or foreigners because those
are different kinds foreigners i feel
like they don't have a concept of like i
was assuming it's foreign but like but
like yes i mean whatever you should
throw up this yeah i don't see a lot of
american asians doing this
that's foreign asian americans go like
this we go like this oh that's cool this
is cool but when it wasn't foreigners i
thought i thought that was weird one of
those white people it's just going up
and just like i was like
they're just like someone died have you
ever seen dura's funeral and they're
driving by and the the four-year-old
son's waving oh yeah no he's like
salutes
i see him all the time in new york all
the time you did all the time he would
always be around i had some friends who
knew him and stuff like that in fact he
used to come to the restaurant
he did yeah he was a handsome son of a
[ __ ] they were all [ __ ] hate he was
but he was like no one had more swag
[ __ ] six two all muscle he you'd see him
with a shirt off rollerblading in
central park guy lived near him so you'd
always see him and it was just like he
was just so good-looking probably nobody
talks about this but not not the
smartest guy in the world yeah that's
really tough
really good looking but just didn't
nothing really he didn't pass that but
he has a sister
or something like that now jfk was a
pipe man he used to lay the pipe and
they just they just sold one of his uh
letters that he wrote to his girl his
side piece in paris yep she sold him my
buddy carmine smith took a shower with
him and is that the girl that died with
him and said he's got he had a piece on
him too
yeah good looking guy though look at him
the whole family cursed but whatever
you think it's a curse or just i mean
dude that many people die non-stop
they also had two children die like
prematurely as well yeah tough tough
girl for that yeah she died too like
with an outlet within hours she was in
love with a calvin klein model i can't
remember the guy's name and she up there
the rumor was she was always having she
could always kind of yeah well she would
leave him
she was still in love she was beautiful
but she was still in love with this one
dude you know what i'm talking about
there's the look at look up got in the
kennedys here caroline
they got that good hair watch this and
he was a calvin klein dude back in the
day he he also lived in my neighborhood
[ __ ] weird you know caroline was set
yeah
that dude
there he is that's him
yeah he was a uh look at it he came up
look him up michael bergen look him up
in that calvin klein when he was younger
he was like although he's a handsome
dude oh yeah watch this
just put calvin klein not just laying
that dick there kennedy's a girl yeah
that's different
bodied up now his body's up as jason but
he's bodied up that he would walk around
new york look at that dick root man
well that by the way
that's who they said used to go she used
to go and and uh yeah because she
couldn't act she couldn't get over it oh
look at him really yeah you got a dick
root
you know i mean not like that not like
that that's
you guys
you just walk around and just like blaze
it's good there that was one back in the
day dude you know what we did yesterday
you know i have uh thick boy uh
authentic baseball jerseys coming out on
friday so we did a photo shoot with like
baseball mitt like actual mids and
gloves and bats and we just played some
catch man and it was so fun it's a good
time it was so fun
now you've never seen a guy more
uncomfortable
around the ball
see now
all right hey hey you were a champion my
daddy was in prison bro you were a child
we didn't play kids and that's fair but
i i do think i don't know i don't think
i don't think you're an american that's
okay and that's all right you'll see
where's my birth certificate you'll see
here
he would throw it like this
and i go chappelle you have so much
sugar in your tank when you're around
balls first of all i don't want to throw
it hard because i don't know i don't
know your skills show the only baseball
skills rumor the myth is in world war ii
when they have a german guy
impersonating american he would study
the accent and all that they'd throw him
this is the rumor they'd reel a baseball
and say let's see you throw a ball now
if you're european especially back then
but even today europeans don't grow up
throwing a ball you get conor mcgregor
they don't first [ __ ]
they don't grow up throwing the ball
it's just not what they do yeah they
kick the [ __ ] out of it we i threw i
probably threw a baseball
i have i i would say i have 10 000 hours
of throwing a baseball to this day i
could throw a ball when boston was one
he was doing it's all you did as a kid i
played cash with my dad all the time
that's all we do when he was home
sorry mark had the best joke of the mark
of the best joke of the day what do you
mean because uh
i was like damn i never grew up because
he's driving me nuts i'm like don't make
the ball you can't beat it i'm like you
ever grew up [ __ ] throwing balls and
then mark goes yeah it's like your dad
was in prison your entire life yourself
chapelle can i just see is that can you
stand
yeah it's not gonna do it justice let me
just because it was like a you know like
that let me just see
just throw an imaginary ball
yeah it's not gonna do it just i'll tell
you what i'll tell you what give him
could you have a piece of paper we have
a [ __ ]
mike has a baseball in his office get me
out get me just get roll up a piece of
paper roll no no that's not i'm telling
you it's not going to work for the
mechanic it's not going to work it's too
light it's too light
he threw me keys yeah just taking this
we're getting amazing we're
yeah uh you just haven't thrown a ball
that was very interesting because your
head went down oh the whole thing was
awesome it's adorable and that's great
well you can't throw a baseball right
now you can throw it to he could throw
it to christian
back up doug
slowly now slowly please don't hit us
slowly
big poppy see that see how he pushes
see how there's a lot of sugar in his
tank
see how he's sugaring all in his tank
he's not he's not letting his wrist he's
not throwing it he's not you just you
just like let you you loosen you loosen
it
see how loose my arm is i'm just i'm
letting it roll maybe maybe we'll take
it outside or something man we don't
want to do this in here
are we teaching chappelle how to play
catchphrase
i mean i'm 34 years old i'm not going to
go out and play cat it was fun
it was fun though oh yeah it wasn't and
then i had the idea for the promo i was
like i told mark i'm like throw the ball
in they hit it so i hit one and i go
like i'm gonna i'm gonna strike out and
i'm gonna break the bat like the pros do
everyone's like you can't break the bat
like i guarantee you'll break this back
but i was like oh my god that's a bad
[ __ ] thing
i [ __ ] swung i miss
and then [ __ ] snap the bat pretty
easy
pretty easy well i really didn't think
you were outside there's no way
the adrenaline was running that's not
that i see i see pro baseball players do
it but they're big it's pretty yeah is
it for you i don't think i couldn't do
it that's that's a lot of [ __ ] what'd
you do just get yeah and then rip the
promo i'm like don't strike out like i
did these jerseys are home runs
that's a great that's a great so
do you have it on on here um mike has it
i don't think we have you have it yeah
send that to me i got to see that that's
so send it to the channel so everybody
can see because whenever baseball
players would break bats
yeah you know what's funny in jail time
i was because i sent the video jam like
look how easy i broke this back and he
goes don't you remember where kids dad
used to always hate on players that
broke the bat like when bo jackson did
it yeah like those bats are so fragile
they're so easy me and jay were like no
they're not but my dad since we were
kids like that ain't [ __ ] that's easy
so you'll see like my adrenaline's going
because i didn't think yeah because i
didn't want to not get it done did you
play baseball yeah yeah yeah in high
school yeah here it is
[Music]
don't strike out like me because these
are home run baby go to thickboy.com
it's nick friday
[Music]
[Laughter]
terrible ad that's something i was
grabbing so hard
it's purposely done like yeah like it's
a 90s baseball commercial
what's good yeah i was laughing boy
brandon shop
that's like an old school baseball card
wait brian you said you played baseball
as a kid like
every kid every kid did yeah i played
every kid for you get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah i played so i i stopped in high
school but yeah you know but even then i
was always but baseball i mean it's
insane like i'm like like being out
there i'm like i got to catch this
[ __ ] little ball he kept going
well when you're i went ah one time when
you're a kid it was very common you did
it a couple times yeah you went
until i was 18 until i was 18 i always
was going out throwing a on facebook
what were you saying like it's a you
said if you get three game of losses
three out of ten
yeah if you if you hit three out of ten
balls no three if you have a three
hundred batting
hall of fame if you if you hit yeah
that's thirty percent that would be the
hardest part you had three out of ten
it's a game of favorite yeah if you go
three and ten the ufc you don't have a
career yeah if you complete three out of
ten passes you're a nfl you don't have a
career if you if you hit three out of
ten shots in the [ __ ] nba you don't
have a career yeah baseball you're a
[ __ ] hall of fame it's a night
getting insane guys what was my boy mark
mcguire doing he was he was beating his
hitting crushing steroids and crushing
balls yeah
he was more about crushing that hall of
fame no because steroids they're haters
they're bonds nope
you should be because barry bonds wasn't
just social mark mcguire yeah he was
also he also won 10 golden gloves barry
bonds could [ __ ] field the ball it
was just fun throwing the ball at me and
mark we're playing like real cats and
he's an athlete he's he grew up yeah
mark yeah yeah i pretend i was doing
double plays and [ __ ] jump in the air i
know yeah
it was fun man
yeah it's fantastic oh guess what daddy
got his residuals for his acting gig
from the movie 127 bucks that's [ __ ]
awesome now you can buy that book of
stamps and buy a vcr
set sag sent me my residuals on the dvd
sales was it from the tax collector that
movie yeah 2017 hit that 127. the girl
said you got a check from saggy i said
oh [ __ ] open that up girl 127. all right
my second special never grow up they had
they had a dvd release i knew i was in
trouble i was like
i'm with the wrong group of people
that's not good dvd releases yeah i
remember they go do you want to do what
do you want to do you want to get some
reviews for the back of the dvd no uh
i'm too depressed to complete to answer
please don't i said all the energy just
left my body
[ __ ] dvd oh gosh
part of part of uh hey we got a lot of
emails about the metaverse comedy club
your brother jay told me yeah but
something some comics doing already yeah
so what yeah he's an awesome
i don't have
yeah well i think that i love brett uh
but um overall you still need the
glasses right everybody can eat the
glasses i mean it's going to happen it's
a good idea five years five to ten years
yeah pretty good about 10 minutes
they're gonna make them glasses
expensive
to start but then eventually you know
it's like those electric cars
yeah they're expensive as [ __ ] at the
job
yeah now or whatever what
tesla's still beasting it though by the
way
if you're in the market for a new car
now the shortage nut holy [ __ ] cars are
all-time these are going above sticker
no matter what they are you're spending
crazy crazy crazy money and cars and
inflation's up six percent or whatever
uh go brandon oh dude i'm telling you
bye good luck bud if i mean how is he
going so far the economy is going to be
it's not
to trouble trouble
i think so i don't know now do you want
to open that whiskey or what do you want
to do with it i do
yeah i've been staring at it look should
we should we can we toast can we get a
little can we get a finally
give me a sparkling liquid
i'll tell us what that mean can we can
we not celebrate can we crack it do i
get a cut of this mm-hmm
you're not gonna give him a little just
a little not gonna let my bee
influence yeah i mean i'm an influencer
all right it's fine i guess my mouth got
his turn give brian a sponsorship deal
yeah come on man
you know
well give him a little something i could
come up with funny ads for it i'll tell
you that much yeah
hey guys are you tired of the
run-of-the-mill whiskey
just do some really dumb [ __ ] ads you
probably just cracked that you could
probably just twist it and what yeah
your label already won an award right
yep two awards
before it even came out yep whiskey pete
sent me a text they said hey man it's
actually pretty good yeah no [ __ ]
whiskey pete
i love whiskey yeah what's this run a
bottle now i think that's 60 bucks
not giving it away but that's worth it
but japanese what's the percentage
japanese and then american bourbon
there's a lot too you hate america what
there's a lot to it as well dude two
years this is a mix of bourbon first
makes ever the market of ha of japanese
whiskey american what do you do you have
to you call it a blended whiskey you
have to and then also there's all these
the rules especially
the thing that took so long is getting
it uh commissioned from the alcohol uh
board but then to get this rating the
the mix approved and then also the the
japanese whiskey it can only be
signified as japanese whiskey if it's
aged 10 years so that to get the whole
barrels finding the bourbon distributors
for 10 years isn't burping the same way
yeah oh yeah but but for [ __ ] for to come
from japa japan and be labeled as
japanese whiskey has come from a certain
barrel so they define those distributors
myself some japanese whiskey oh nothing
better right yeah my favorite besides
tiger thick is called nico whiskey
you'll be careful how you pronounce it
nico coffee grains is my favorite that's
my favorite dog oh it's a it's a coffee
uh
no
you just use your hands though
thanks buddy
see chin's licking his lips i know
where's my cup little whiskey buddy
getting me get some chins thank you
christian [ __ ] rude christian
does anyone else want a glass yeah so
you don't keep running out of there
cats i hate her i don't drink something
i'll take one
well i've seen you drink cat but that's
what very rarely i saw you i saw you
wasted in nashville it's whatever
i never followed you
oh thank you a little bit like that's
full-blown baddie man
like your dad who's looking at your
pictures and i i'm like see and that's
fair i realize i have to post more if
i'm on only fans that's just like
instagram is a promotional twitter i
don't see anything yeah you probably
don't want to no it's a little
system
that's like i'm looking at her going
well that's a good looking gal yeah i
don't want to jack up
why you
just went up to 500. are we going to
talk about the fit you're wearing
doesn't that make you feel insecure yeah
we got to talk about this yeah too
about what
yeah well can you see me or no
oh i [ __ ] love camouflage strokes oh
yes
i'm sorry just a zero dark 30 fit cat oh
glad you said something drops friday
built collab with thick boy
oh thanks chris we have we have the
night camo too it's black and white
mark how about how much better did mark
look in the outfit bro he lit photo
shoot today
it's hard taking pictures with mark
he [ __ ] he looks good mark's look
good in the outfit i look like [ __ ] yeah
does he look good in that yeah let me
show you we have some we have some funny
pictures
i'm gonna send this to you jim
hope
oh yeah
oh yeah baby
come on now
[Laughter]
daddy looking and he's liking
i like it very much it's a it's actually
an excellent blend it tastes like scotch
man that's nice huh tastes like scotch
pizza hater on whiskey and he was like
dude it's good i said no
yeah he drinks so much it's actually
very smooth yeah that was the number one
thing i started with japanese whiskey
it's got smoothies
yes ma'am
it's nice it doesn't have like a little
wild turkey kick to it no no no i'm not
gonna finish it only because i gotta i
gotta train after this that's kind of
what you're training my dreams after
training today i work out
i don't work out after this
what specifically brian oh there he is
so here we go
thank you now go to the next one
and this is break dancing
very good
now do you see the guys in the
background with their shirts off oh yeah
see you guys with tits in the back yeah
this guy's gotta do there's a black guy
today with a shirt off oh my god brendon
you i like how you said what's up to him
you're like damn what's up dog you
looking swole
he said you are too i i appreciate that
but i'm not so people just take their
shirts are not a thing is that bradley
martin in the background no no okay
that guy is jacked and that's us break
dancing yeah yeah that's amazing that
does look like a sci-fi or river dancing
one or two
but look how much better mark looks yeah
mark looks sweet look at that what what
mark's in that night camo that's a good
look guys
it's uh
man i got shoulders on me huh
you're a big strong i feel like this
this area of me
is like i'm not i'm not mad at it at all
yeah
you know what i mean
okay i think that's just at the end of
the day you're an athlete oh this is my
favorite picture look at look how
friendly chappelle looks here
you're telling me you wouldn't buy
whatever this guy's selling if you if
you pop
you tell me you want to adopt that guy
i mean i'm taking them first round
why does this look like an adoption
photo it does look like it does it does
it looks like that's how my adopted
folks got me yeah nine news the cutest
one the cutest one did he look cute
there yeah he's a cutie pie that's going
to sell some shirts who's gobbling baby
dude
look at him just friendly
mm-hmm comfortable here are the little
outfits i like them i haven't seen these
before it's like a joke it just came out
just came out or it drops friday yeah
trendy nice thank you man all right
chill what do you got i mean i could use
the top would i wear that or am i too
old camo a little too old for thick boy
aren't i
just skinny and too old or what no
fixing the heart dude
it really is
i need some clothing maybe i'll i'll
send you some i'm gonna die again and
get you that and whiskey all right well
i'd like uh what are we gonna send we
gotta i wanna do something for our boy
eric because he [ __ ] hooked me up so
hard send him a dick pic
maybe some whiskey what do we do i don't
know what do i send him i'm gonna i'm
gonna give him a gift let's send him
something i'm buying him yeah well yeah
what would he want i'm a rolex isn't
that the worst
yeah
i hate i hate people who come in
terrible solutions my mother my mother
every time i'm losing my hair so i got
to figure out she goes we're a wig dead
serious
well i'm with your mom on that but yeah
but a wig is yeah it's it's so extreme
so you don't need to don't don't ever do
it to be fair
but i'm not wearing one i can't even
wear a watch it's much less a wig i
can't it's another imagine brian waking
up every morning fixing his wig i mean
that would be so sad i bet your girl i
just show up with a full head of hair if
you go straight bald we have to go wig
dude yeah but you'll be like oh [ __ ] are
they coming up with ways to clone hair
i've been waiting how's jeff hey jeff
bezos [ __ ] space dude work on the hair
daddy i agree i thought there was like
multiple things out there to help you
with that
yeah it looks like you're [ __ ] you
look like an annie oh look at this okay
well that's lit as [ __ ] that could be
you brian he looks like [ __ ] you brian
but you tripping then the hair on the
bottom is [ __ ] fire that looks like a
piece i don't know i'm doing that though
i'm not doing pieces i want to grow real
hair if i can grow real hair everybody
will know it hey bezos come on dude [ __ ]
going to mars start working oh that's my
boy you got i'm [ __ ] telling you
pieces of [ __ ]
i watch squid games for you [ __ ]
idiots all right watch yellowstone we
don't have the app you're out of control
it's not an app it's on peacock it know
it's on regular channel peacock
it used to be the old like spike
it's on regular tv you don't have to
have not having a regular tv that's why
i'm going to watch
the app yeah
all right
man the best show ever well don't get
carried away 13 million people watch
first episode it's a good show for
regular tv rip
oh fantastic he's the best huh 13
million is unheard of nowadays unheard
of regular gold goldbergs is like one of
the top shows
on a good week their hit show gets maybe
six million views which is insane which
is insane now 13 mil for debut on a
paramount network on the paramount now
come to the dun ranch it's interesting
what's your what's your dun ranch i will
i know i'm watching it i like it what's
your take on netflix longevity in
comparison are they just i know that
disney plus just superseded just past
netflix with all the kids [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's interesting i guess
there's arena there's lanes for both of
them because i think like netflix like
one of my favorite shows is uh narcos
like that's fantastic dude and i [ __ ] i
love like
i wish uh i wish yellowstone was on
netflix because i [ __ ] hate having to
wait week to week yeah like i told my
girl i'm like i'd pay 20 grand if
paramount would just [ __ ] send me the
entire series yeah i hate waiting dudes
it sucks and then all day they make you
wait huh
every sunday you gotta [ __ ] wait and
i have something to look forward to and
daddy likes yeah but i would love just
to binge watch it there's something nice
about having a weight oh it is nice i
mean in a weird way it gives you you
look forward to your sunday that's the
building the football and yellowstone
come on man that's that's how we lived
back in the day there's something about
delayed gratification but i like how
netflix how you can just binge watch it
and then they're like squid games like
yeah where else would you put this great
game did you ever hear like narcos then
mine hunter yeah like all their series
you know like midnight mass all that
[ __ ] what did you ever hear how they how
they uh did that experiment where it was
it was a delayed gratification thing
where they gave kids they took kids and
they said you can have oh there's
marshmallows right yeah you can have one
now if you wait till tomorrow we'll give
you three if you wait an hour or i think
it was literally like 10 minutes they
were very small kids if you wait ten
minutes we'll give you two or three and
the kids that waited were able to wait
the 10 minutes or 50 minutes they
followed them fared way better in life
later on it's really i'm glad you said
that because i do that with tiger
because we'll go to the you know if he
does something well or something or i'll
hype something up and like you do this
you can get a toy and we'll go to the
toy store and he'll he'll like go up and
down the aisle which toy store i mean
target so we'll go up in because no toy
stores no more way to go toys r us but
we'll go up and down the aisles and i
can tell you and found some i'm like
dude you can wait and i'll take you to a
real toy store and you get exactly what
you want and a better gift or you can
get some [ __ ] you want right now and
he'll always wait always always waiting
he was all wait papa wow
that's really nuts
you know um i think gavin newsom was uh
i think there was that measure to put
gender neutral toys gender neutral toys
they did it with uh mr potatoes
so
cool
yeah that's important
to all our challenges let's make sure
now i rip new some up a little bit in
the special oh you do rip them up a
little bit there you go
good yep see how that goes well i think
it'll go well yeah right yep and you
know if you don't like it suck it yeah
suck it who's gonna be like how dare you
i like me who do you know avian liberals
like he's too much for us yeah well like
you like i don't think i've heard anyone
that says i don't know anyone who i
don't know literally like right there
there are plenty of people there's not
pelosi yeah i mean it's just a lot of
it's like you ever met a kamala harris
fan a lot of young people who are coming
out of colleges that are straight-up
socialists and comments we hear what
happened with dave chappelle you can go
do a talk as old as high school
and they protested what the students did
for him not to come there so the school
was like all right dave i guess we don't
want you oh really
how crazy is that brian let's take your
break dude and shut your yapper because
when it comes to health care it's
important to make sure you're getting
your money's worth health care is the
whole deal crowd health crowd health
offers a more flexible affordable health
care option without the hassle of
insurance okay so while you're shopping
around don't forget to head to join
crowdhealth.com fit find out how crowd
health can save you up to 40 to 60
in health care costs a lot of money dude
explain it it isn't health insurance no
it's a modern way to pay medical
expenses crowd health is a community of
people who are tired of paying into a
broken system being in the crowd health
community can save hundreds of dollars
monthly and put thousands of dollars
back in your pocket it's flexible all
right the membership as a monthly
subscription start or stop when you want
all right it's got transparent pricing
customized to fit your needs it's also
very simple use their app find nearly
any doctor in the country with a quality
rankings i've been waiting for them to
do something like this yep here we go
dude scan bills and throw them away
press the button receive virtual care
anytime any
future right here yeah this is the
future we're living in it it gets rid of
the insurance middleman and passes the
savings on to its members so 100 of your
monthly membership pays for actual
health care costs keeping the whole
crowd health community staying healthy
while keeping more money in your pocket
that's a big future this is sort of the
this is the answer to all these really
high healthcare crowd health is able to
offer amazing prices because of his
community of health conscious members
for limited time you guys get your first
month free after you've been a member
crowd health will include a fitness
wearable that's 30 days try risk-free
plus fitness wearable just go to join
crowdhealth.com fit enter the code
fighter sign up that's join
crowdhealth.com fit promo code final
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a community-powered alternative
terms and conditions may apply yeah so
they were going to hold an event later
this month where they brought dave
chappelle in because he's been
fundraising millions of dollars for his
old school um i believe for you he's
been doing that for a while yeah he's
been doing it for a while but with the
backlash from his latest uh special a
lot of the students there said that they
were going to do a walkout if this had
ac this event had
dave
it's always the students not the
teachers yeah if i'm because he puts too
much money in their pocket if i'm dave i
pull all funding and i go to the
competing high school the competitor and
go all right i'm gonna give to you guys
can i talk here and go sure they are at
the school though um the school is still
accepting the money and they're actually
just uh pushing the date of the event to
i believe april of next
year yeah it might just be a scheduling
thing dude if i came home and my kid if
he's not you guys hey i remembered if i
came on my debt my tiger was like hey
dad we're protesting dave chappelle
supposed to come to school
my initial reaction to this article was
outrage outrage and confusion because i
genuinely couldn't understand how a
group of people could have been who
benefited so much from having a famous
alumnus could turn that person turn on
that person despite everything he's done
for them but then i remembered we were
dealing with literal children
enough to grasp the concentration about
this company amen yeah or at the very
least digest what he said after the fact
and let that inform their opinion i love
this he was sad but true that's how
people operate in 2021
what's even sadder is the fact that now
the burden of buying supplies will most
likely fall back on their underpaid
teachers oh well anything take a stand
damn who wrote this pat i love pat
go go up chin it gives the writer yeah
yep pat's great who is pat for barstool
martial writer great writer
really good articles yeah he's great oh
okay yeah he's he's the best one i think
out of mom you just keep going damn
what
take it easy
guys it's torque two's morning guys it's
twerk too what it's twerk tuesday oh
she's oh nasty nas you don't know her
no oh dude hit it chin
up music hit it chin hold up chin
bringing out the current of this
flattering
oh wait do you see her ass daddy oh
that's pumpkin friday
yeah mom
and she makes a ton of money doing this
i've seen her luxie pantera backsides
but no she's so talented with it though
oh yeah it's a real art yeah
i think she took your classes what's
that what i think she uh taught classes
for a while oh she's still going to
seminars like she's [ __ ] oh she does
look at that ass dude a white girl
teaching twerking classes yeah it's 20
21 baby girl do i guarantee oh black
girls are usually way better why people
always why people always steal black
people's inventions they're always like
i'll take it from here thanks a lot guys
yeah but you mad at this
yeah i'm not crazy about her ass to be
honest with you
get out you've seen a much better ass
get out get the [ __ ] a little uh
you know
oh it's too much for you i don't know
if she likes glutes not ass yeah that's
what i like yes there that's a great
that's exactly right oh there you go i
get you oh no go to her go to the black
girl we'll find some no
go go
there you go
all right you calm down brian you get
pretty brendan you guys are matching too
oh where's the dress same well she's a
thicker boy work work work work work
oh she's doing a little more flavor with
it okay a little more stripper-ish yeah
let's see the other one yeah
[ __ ] computer animated
yeah well
that's twerking brian
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna touch
that
and there we are
that girl might have been one of the
originators but then the people up the
game just like anything else you had you
had anderson silva then you have israel
out of sign that's all sure
oh good though we can't just go there
you got to take a look at that
those pants are nice
oh yeah those leggings went viral a few
years ago
it's like uh the winter sundress i'm
very happy with that
see that it's like big but it's also
kind of flatter isn't it yeah i i i'm a
fan i don't call that i'm a fan of all
not afraid of it no no definitely not
afraid it's very strange i'm not afraid
and it's funny how quiet
men get very quiet
men stop moving oh that's because we'll
have boners brian
it's gay if you talk to me of a boner do
you know that i agree yeah do you
remember having getting boners in class
and just like tuck it up oh man i would
do that i get it all the school business
i would do that
there you go
well now
now we're cooking
and it's a white girl we've come home we
come home
dude i used to i used to do the old
submarine remember the summer anything i
popped out of the water like this i
would take that that's a girl and just
pop it up top of the jeans yep that's
guys would hold their binders or their
backpacks like right in front there you
go that's the old trick right there
oh jesus christ
those jean shorts don't leave much
imagination no they don't it's like slow
i can see your [ __ ]
i mean i see your [ __ ]
i mean why you wear jeans they don't
work well when it's cold
i mean isn't it crazy 80 plus degree
weather it's like dude you could get
literally i'll deposit my entire bank
out into her bank account
that's what happens you got to help her
get through nursing school whatever
what else you got jim
shout out to dave chappelle and [ __ ]
them kids yep um so the internet got
really mad at kendall jenner for going
to her friend's wedding this past
weekend in a very scandalous dress
they're saying that she took a lot of uh
attention away from the bride i agree
with that because kendall jenner comes
to your wedding what was the bride look
like uh much more modest but it's like a
regular bride yeah she's a white dress
yeah she's a beautiful shirt kendall jen
yeah that's my thing if you invite
kendra i invite little knobs or else
that's why everyone's gonna assume they
show up in some [ __ ] if i invite bruce
buffer i'm gonna assume he comes in with
a [ __ ] crazy top meryl streep at the
height of her career didn't go to her
sister's wedding for that exact reason
she's showing up seller i just want to
up she was yeah
it was yeah it would take away egomans
uh let's see uh let's see her dress
though i'd like uh if i can get a
is that her that's
kellen jenner is on the left dress
kendall jenner i mean that's a kendall
yeah that's that's a wedding dress yeah
well
people are upset
yeah people are upset but don't invite
the bad ideas to party if you can't hang
yeah
it's like being mad if you're a comedian
then you invite [ __ ] a funnier
comedian all right what'd you think
wasn't happening of course you can't
take this [ __ ] over gotta say that's my
really hot friend and that's the way
she's pretty too yeah it's fine
people were gonna stare at kindle
regardless yeah but people are also
saying that uh kendall and her group of
friends were there so bella hadid haley
bieber and they were all wearing kind of
more normal wedding appropriate dresses
and then there's kendall so people are
saying like she was trying to be a
picnic she's trying to upstage these
girls like get your tits out there
they're super super it's very
competitive out there to be in this in
this world oh yeah
he didn't wear some crazy shirts i also
don't think the friend cares
right yeah
i don't know
it doesn't matter
you know they're bringing slo hey man
hey man come on
like you invite me to your party brian
i'm coming dude
he's coming with a hat yeah yeah yeah
they're like jesus you're gonna bring
mark you can bring mark harley there
with no she's walking marquia takes your
shirt off just strutting in slow motion
even though it's not slow motion you're
moving you asking for daddy i like it
you want the goods don't worry ladies
here you go if you don't want a big dick
at your party don't invite you're tired
of [ __ ] old guys yep
of course
so the lead singer of brass against uh
actually performed on thursday and at
the very end of the set she decided that
she was going to pee on a fan hard pitch
she actually pissed on his face later on
the very next day the band actually had
to issue an apology saying that she got
out of hand dude watch this history
again i've never pissed this harder but
he was willing that's another thing he
was willing oh come on you put the gopro
chris this is where you thought wait
what is this what is this band this is
[ __ ] so nice they do like razor
blades machine gun but let's
hey she's bodied up b she pisses so hard
she takes a legit piss i i know women
can pee this heart
but she's all yeah
she uh is she a [ __ ] um punk rocker
this is as punk as it gets brian look at
this piss
[Applause]
that's some gigi allen [ __ ] oh my god
what's that buffalo gg allen have you
heard of gigi alex
pissing that's my generation
that's a dirty old man oh he's jamming
in piss
he's all fat
well that's pretty strange
that's pretty strange would you let any
famous person find it
[ __ ] on your face not [ __ ] let's stay
with piss oh sorry that's not what she
ate for breakfast it depends on what she
ate for breakfast let's stay with pizza
clams and a pork chop then yes oh
why not oh now that's gross
oh that's sorry so the [ __ ] on my face
is fine and then i added to it i saved
no too much
pork chop
well if you're in a warehouse too much
if you're gonna stick your finger in the
[ __ ] cage you're getting bit how's
that i mean don't if you want to get
into that with me that's just i'll beat
everybody in there
you wouldn't let atlanta's worst [ __ ] in
your face well were you like yeah and
i'm gonna shade a lot of chili and sour
cream yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna up it i'm
gonna up it disgusting i mean you
definitely raised the bar on that hey
bro that's a little too far
is it though
is it
all right would you let anybody piss on
your [ __ ] like you would
you wouldn't let him go you know
nothing there's not a woman not in any
of that [ __ ] no it grows it's not sexual
christian why are you making a weird
look would you yeah who would elizabeth
hurley for one you little [ __ ] on you
pissed not [ __ ] yeah shit's a little
different yeah it's just a little
different pee look it just just gets
going my sister called me
her first day at college and one of the
guys got drunk and he was at university
of vermont hell yeah and she goes she
goes i go how is it going she goes i
don't like it here at all and i say why
she goes
this really nice guy
felt like he got really drunk because
his friend made him get drunk she was so
honest because he did he he fell asleep
on a couch
in our in our dorm area main area and
they took a [ __ ] off yeah and i go
welcome to college i start laughing i go
where they go he he had a curled chip
oh my
baby you know what god said i was like
ah boys will be boys animal house baby
animal house that's what it was that
that backpack hot coil [ __ ] though 40
years ago kids yeah that stuff stuff i
had a homie slap dog [ __ ] on my face one
time oh wow we were drunk oh yeah yeah
it's one of those crusty problems i
don't i don't play with disney i don't
like [ __ ] no
there's nothing sexual about it i don't
like this either that's like when they
talk about squirting that's urine yeah
so this is pee pee baby nah that's pee
pee straight up pee pee yeah [ __ ] off
there's no one alive i want the [ __ ] or
piss on i mean what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
i talked to a doctor christian was like
hell yeah
if they're hot enough yeah
i know right no no i wouldn't do it
regularly i wouldn't do this
you have to be like hot enough and like
megan fox like elizabeth hurley [ __ ]
millionaires like hurley
oh wow it might be just hot older woman
uh english
shoes
[Music]
it's everybody's generation man i love
her sorry i forgot i forgot you showed
me before i have a friend i don't
realize that was her she's [ __ ]
smoking was she with hugh grant she was
there we go see
thank you dude how do you not know her
look i do i just said it she used today
15 years ago dude someone said milk
she's so ridiculous oh it's [ __ ]
stupid you know i'd let her piss on me
go what do you know
god see hershey's all about her son is
slightly hotter than she is
look at his son i can't get over i know
he's talked about this before but her
son
it got an attractive human being if he
gets arrested for a crime and has to go
to regular jail his ass again torah whoa
well i mean i've never that's him right
there that's him look at his eyes wow
i'm not a gay man but [ __ ] it
i mean that that's astonishing how
beautiful he is
his lips he's obviously a big model i
mean i don't like his hairy chest that
grosses now but i know but he's got a
face on him like i've never seen he's
very gay it's real is he insanely gay of
course look at his friends
yeah
in the back i mean just a gorgeous human
being is what it is man yeah he's abused
what if he ain't gay oh he is i can't
yeah he is god you don't dress like that
chevelle and not prince
prince was they always say prince was
getting all the hoes sure and ambrose
they never said that who's their host
bros and ho he gets them all
all right his hair's insane
private person
what does he say he's a private person
surprised he don't tell nobody oh dude
we don't need to look into this
we're all set no no we yeah we got this
i'm pretty sure yeah case closed
we call this first 48 seconds
that's right there you go
that's right oh there it is hairy legs
too yeah i wish you would shave down if
he was my man you know what i'm saying
now now let me ask you gonna be a
twinkle four regular dude or you're a
bro
if you had that face and that look how
would you even if he cut his hair he
looks it's still feminine he looks
well i mean you almost have to embrace
you gotta [ __ ] him
no what brilliant
good for you brandon hold on no i don't
know the question
hold on let me finish i thought you were
saying what would i do if he's your
friend if he's your buddy yeah and
you're a straight man yeah of course you
[ __ ] him
no that's what i'm saying yes and it's
not gay no way but about dude what
happens is you get drunk and he's
looking at you and you're like those
pouty little legs
blue eyes all of that
you're nantucket you're in there and the
wine's flowing and the wine's flowing
and we're [ __ ] broken
and by the way you're [ __ ] him face
on face it's not yeah
you're passionate you're like i might
drop an elbow
and and then i find out i'm like that's
hard
i'm not hard in that ass i go i go and i
go dude wiener the wiener
wiener to wiener i don't call it
oh it's mangina yeah
yeah we're weird
face to face dude as gay you'll take
your eyes off them
passionate sex dude because he is very
he's so androgynous you can't put your
that makes me gay it is what it is look
at his hair
it's nuts man yeah he's he's uh he likes
to have a good time well look at the way
he's you know i by the way i don't know
if it's his mom or him at some point you
know
i'm confused myself
that's what i'll tell you guys i'm like
dude i think i hooked up with elizabeth
earlier
are you sure yeah i don't know dude
you decide what am i going to do
machine gun kelly which was confusing
could be the sun there's no difference
dude i don't know what to say boy she's
she's uh look at him with the model
which one which one's female there i
don't know i don't know i don't know
i mean i i mean seriously look at his
hair you literally can't tell he just
has a lot of feminine he has a lot of
estrogen in his body
that's fine he might be intersex i don't
[ __ ] know
either way it's all good is what i have
to say that's what i'm saying it's all
good look at that photo
fantastic the hair is fantastic oh with
a rubik's cube i see i wouldn't see the
you see how they put he's so handsome
that's not handsome me that's double
gorgeous i'd say that i agree he's just
a gorgeous human being that's coming
from a straight man straight as it gets
i i i'm telling you that nantucket the
wine's flowing
we [ __ ]
i hate to say that dude
he would be so all over you here he is
brendan let's go swimming waiting and
i'd like yeah yeah walk in my trunks
let's go we don't have any oh we don't
have trunks in the point [ __ ] it yeah
yeah [ __ ] it and then you look you're
like i'm a little thing
i like that i think you mean manly oh
dude it's on dude
and nobody's around
and it's his nighttime fighting stay
flat well get on the back of my bike
i'll pedal us there
i'll pedal this there oh i have bad news
this big mansion only one bad daddy ah
[ __ ] you're gonna cuddle you would
cuddle him that's the [ __ ] up thing
there's a man out there that you would
wiener wiener too we're not going butts
to nuts
we're going weiner to wiener dude
yeah where is his dad what's his dad
this is his dad hugh grant no
this one
maybe i'm down down down that knocks you
grant i don't think what happened i
don't think that's okay
let me see him with shaved head well who
are these [ __ ]
hey man don't be jealous dude take it
easy
relax is that him
[Laughter]
is that him i mean
dude i'm staying away from nantucket
staying away from nantucket
is that him with a shaved head yeah
i think he gets it pulled back like that
was a ball cap
it's not right dude we're so similar
i think it's pulled back like mine you
know he's got a bald cap on dude we have
so many similarities it's true god he's
good with a camera
big boy studio is higher yep i mean we
are looking yup
i don't know if we can afford
oh christian your show fired if he takes
the jump
why am i fired brendan christian starts
growing history she comes back as his
boyfriend
look at that distracting how tall is he
six one six two maybe he might be tall
let's say six one yeah i'd say yeah he
might be five of those is he six 140
pounds is that six feet one inches oh
there you go there you go
there you go
you've done a study of him i haven't
it's just we have this weird connection
does he have an old link
dude he's english holy [ __ ] dude i'm
half english this is stupid
he's probably got a great accent too oh
my god dude yeah you want to see an
interview or something like that yeah
are you guys in love you know they're so
into them right now no let me get my
hand at my pants we're crushing hard
though yeah
so funny
[Music]
i don't like him when he has his hair
long or short see when he's older maybe
yeah you've been with long hair those
pictures he might well go for you let's
see that our guarantee he's got all
right we'll just watch the first one
yeah let's see this a brand new season
of a little longer are these idiots
did mom give you anything for you to
take don't be annoying
a cockney accent dude
look heavy on the [ __ ] take care of
business thing what i'm so humane of
course you can really hope he's good and
oh [ __ ] he was in a movie role i felt
really at home it was good i'm slightly
hooked on it now it's great no damn well
i don't wanna wear that suit on stage
like that
yeah he's um let's get him there
he might be straight i mean there
he might be straight in general yeah i
might yeah straight as mulholland road
dude but sometimes you get you're so
beautiful that you fall down
thank you for drinking
oh yeah you'll get carsick yeah little
sketch in we call him mahon road
we call him a home boulevard
so have you guys heard about the drama
between tim dillon and michael che sure
have no um so fill the boomer in
uh tim dillon recently posted about a
sketch on snl where they were making fun
of joe rogan taking horse training lazy
too like it was like they keep they keep
going with the horse uh stuff it's kind
of boring and it's like well you know
like it's been proven like cnn came
there anymore because they get sued so
it's like a lazy joke the rest of it was
pretty funny like says sesame street it
was ted cruz street and that was funny
yeah and the rest was funny burt and
ernie were great on it big bird was
decent on it
but this wasn't a very good joe rogan
impersonation
like i picked the skinniest guy to play
him yeah tim dillon went and said that
this skit was lazy it wasn't funny but
he does say that snl is a very
like funny show in general but lately a
lot of the sketches that they've been
doing is very lazy very like
just they're not trying very hard so so
michael chase someone sent this so he's
right about it so yeah of course he's
right so you know how michael che is the
head writer for saturn at live so tim
said he you know their hacks on their
blah blah so mike it gets word to
michael che who has a special that
dropped today and he goes hello you got
to be kidding me tim dillon what's the
world coming to he obviously don't know
the beast of tim tim dillon all caps
tim [ __ ] dylan all caps look i don't
want no trouble
and then uh someone goes dude he makes
190k a month on patreon he goes i don't
care if it's a zillion i know tim dillon
he ain't what you think he is he's a
sweet humble guy who really tried it
stand up got nowhere became a media
personality because it's much easier and
we're all very happy for him but don't
get fresh to him and then tim lit him up
here
you missed it you missed it where yeah
slow down tim goes
here's the reality i sell more tickets
than michael che ever has he did just
out the beacon theater which is enormous
in new york because i don't think he's
allowed to use the website per his job
correct life alumni can't be on there uh
and i've built something on my own that
he could never do che has done well for
a drunk you can barely read but the show
sucks and he knows it
wow what did chase say
all fair point
i want no trouble good for michael j i
mean jay i mean
right now though random person
it's him and sam talent yeah i i and
you're we're all very proud of him you
know i don't want no trouble but in the
words of prodigy what do you say oh he
played it seriously folks what's the
world coming he won't let it go no i
like it but hey chase being witty too
last time i saw tim knows three years
ago and he was so michael chase the head
writer dude say what you want about
michael he's a beast tim's also a beast
you're not gonna say nothing too here's
the difference when he's like i want no
smoke
tim tim is uh you know he got famous
from the on the internet so he's not
from a network so tim's fans are going
to light michael che the [ __ ] up because
they're all on there yeah so he's
getting eaten alive right now but i
think if this is all a play to get uh
uh attention to a special because if you
go to his instagram it's just a picture
of the special no michael chase he just
dropped a special on netflix today
that's all he's doing
that's cool
tell me honestly i want no problem i
don't want that i like how he can he
just repeats that
i didn't know he's a great joker he's
great oh dude monster
you don't get to be head writer on snl
without being a monster you also don't
want to go you also don't want to go
after tim dillinger is that wrong
it's just pictures netflix but look
netflix out now
and you know it is what it is
elevens were dope no michael j is a
monster i love that he's just not he's
you know he's not like tim is on [ __ ]
social media so he can get eaten alive
by tim fence yeah but all he cares about
his views for us especially also he he
trolls a lot on on social media michael
yeah
you don't you don't want to rattle tim's
cage though he'll eat you a lot tim's a
monster
it's tim also makes one that shit's good
for both of them
yeah agree yeah
it's good for both of them why don't you
get uh jen i almost said tim they said
tit
uh this is another person on the set of
rust who had a spider bite i didn't look
at the picture yet because this this
really does
right yeah it's a recluse it's in new
york or it's in uh new mexico also
are [ __ ] rough they they they see it
yeah so they eat the skin away they
thought he might lose his arm yeah but
he's he's healing the way he should have
to remove
i definitely want to see it okay i'm not
looking that's his what is his shoulder
dude
that's his [ __ ] shoulder
that [ __ ] well that's nice
all the dead flesh because that spider
can't spread that spider bite that's i
can't believe i'm looking at this right
now i don't know i've ever seen it just
looks like a piece of beef how the [ __ ]
did they save his arms that's nuts god
hey thank god for modern day medicine
yeah what the [ __ ] would you do i'll sew
it together with dental floss that's his
arm dude oh i'm not gonna look through
that's incredible that's crazy i can't
believe they said that's one just this
one's just a little bit salvage [ __ ] i
don't know how skinny that might [ __ ]
hurt bro that's a brown recluse
and that and that's them attacking the
situation quickly right
not really not really no he said that he
made like six calls to the to the team
and they didn't return his calls because
somebody died dude oh no wait so yeah he
actually did get treatment right away
but as far as getting workers comp to
get paid for this dude injury they
wouldn't answer him back rack up the
bill and get your [ __ ] arms yeah
you're gonna [ __ ] die and that that
that'll [ __ ] you up that's crazy
what is that [ __ ] movie
um did you guys see this yet yeah
you see this brian no
all right i'll just play it for you why
would you buy a ticket to the exact show
and then go on stage she's drunk you can
kind of tell she's drunk she does look
kind of drunk yeah goddamn she gives
white people a bad name and they're
gonna call karen i'm sure you turn this
up oh they did what did she do
all right so she didn't like the joke
but then the what a big story here is
that sharon stone also posted this
below his description oh what up sharon
stone
man it's a goddamn comic show what the
[ __ ] it is
what's the problem she took offense to a
joke yeah
who's the lady talking to him the
manager it seems like someone that works
there yeah
where is security what they come up
but why so late yeah where is security i
know it's super late this comedy zone in
charlotte
tonight
[Music]
describing my life is insulting
get the [ __ ] get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
off this how about sharon stone
it's about the artist if you don't like
it go home it's entertaining just go
home not your ideas it's drunk how about
security yeah
shows up oh look at how drunk she's ten
minutes later she's an [ __ ]
[ __ ] white get that [ __ ] out of
here
look at how drunk she is get the [ __ ]
out of here like i don't understand why
she thought she was gonna make a change
right there because he goes on to the
next city he does the [ __ ] same [ __ ]
no what do you think you know what i
mean like what do you like what do you
i don't know i like uh
dropping facts
right if you don't like it go home it's
entertainment not your ideas yeah
afian crockett good that's good for him
he's getting athletician he gets more i
don't know there you go yeah he called
him out is he is he uh in l.a or new
york uh i think apheon's out here yeah
yeah he started off on wallace
the original original funny dude funny
funny funny you've done a lot of movies
and stuff good for him he does pretty
good impressions
yeah he's pretty he's pretty funny
talented dude
yeah she was up there for a long like
way too long the fact that she even got
up there yeah that's nuts like like
security what's up do you think there's
a dude they'd come up faster they should
come out they should come up faster
yeah yeah that's just the club not being
on it that's charlotte comedy zone i'm
not sure what do you think i'm there
there's a charlotte and there's a
jacksonville right yeah i bet that's
charlotte
yeah well i mean it's insane what else
you got jen
this is uh
i just saw this video
and it looked cool it's a lamborghini
[Music]
it's a souped-up huracan
oh my god sick right
what is this
it is a lambo
so the thing about this is it's a it's a
wrap i guess it's this particular thing
is a wrap
yeah that color's wrapped
but it's like you can't bite it from the
factory how do you get the fire like
that what is that oh dude when i went to
his page
uh has fire it's just the exhaust
oh
yeah
okay yeah i just thought it was cool
you don't care right
maples had a bunch of these [ __ ] guys
i'm trying to eat my pizza you know
naples like the richest
zip code oh yeah 60 million dollar
mansion stupid and you see some cars you
see some
cars a lot of whites a lot of whites
step on your opener
except for my louise louise shout out to
louise
great dudes great dude what's this
well the video's not that great but
apparently this is a very rare battle
now before you before you run this i
just want to say this if you're a water
buffalo all due respect they call them
black death they're bad [ __ ]
if you're a water buffalo i just want to
say this before i watch this
the last thing you want to do is lock
horns
with a reno especially on land dude is
that the proper way to say green that's
the way i say it
is it just is the does the video suck
it's very short
dang it yeah no
no i i i i'm i'm coming away right now
on no planet does this [ __ ] thing win
just does either one of them die chad
they don't die but this is a rare battle
we don't see on footage
hell yeah dude
buffalo has balls he ain't having it
dude dude
he's in there
right there
oh god no it's not good rhino doesn't
[ __ ] around why don't the restaurant
also the hunters the homies are rolling
i know how can buffalo dude he's he's
got balls
i hope he's a rolling i don't understand
why the other rhinos don't get involved
they're they're rolling up they don't
want to know other rhinos aren't those
other runners
now see if mr rhino gets his horn in
that thing's underbelly it's going to be
a big that's what he's trying to do he's
going to be lying food but that [ __ ]
buffalo is staring him down yeah
all right
i wish one of them died but
well i'll tell you there are plenty of
videos where elephants kill water
buffalo oh yeah and rhinos oh yeah yeah
let us get you jeff bezos is saying that
um eventually earth will just be a
vacation spot and people will be living
in space
look forward to that
i'm staying here
i don't need to go to space i don't
think this is for us oh like our
generation yeah he's saying generations
not like later on oh they're like 100
years earth is something that you visit
i i don't like when he talks this way
but he's he knows he's no he doesn't
dude
amazon just knowing how the the world
works
shipping boxes
you think he built that [ __ ]
spaceship
dude people who are good at capitalism
like that don't doesn't mean that they
know what the future holds no but they
also have a connection to a lot of
people that are super smart that we
don't have connections to yeah but
that's true we've been talking about
space travel and living in space he's
not saying now so
yeah i mean listen in 500 years yeah and
the two like biggest most famous
guys that have been changing the world
are him and william elon musk yeah oh
yeah
not william
yeah i don't know if i'd say changing
the world chin i mean amazon's dope but
also saying hey earth is going to be a
place we visit in 500 years like okay i
would say jeff bezos is super bored and
yeah having to go into dude how about
you fix my boy's [ __ ] hair problem
yeah instead of getting a [ __ ]
marshmallow i really like you guys both
have shitty hair i really like good hair
you got no hair i'm getting depressed
about my hair sometimes like i look at
it and i go hard to have a good day
today yeah are you still taking the the
pills no but i got to get back on you've
been saying that for years i know
actually
prevention is keys i know dude and i'm
not on it hims.com code you gotta get on
that one
it keeps as well i [ __ ] order my
hymns uh this is the last one i just saw
this pop up
so apparently this mma fighter in guam
had an argument with the doctor it seems
like they're they're homies right had
argument's doctor about the coveted
vaccine can he stab him with a bone a
bone an animal bone
they were eating together earlier i'm
thinking like a rib of some sort but
they were eating together earlier so use
that bone to stab him and kill him
yeah he'd debate over a coven 19 vaccine
stand him in the throat with an animal
bone i would assume a baby back rib from
a meal that two had sheared they shared
a full rack of ribs
and then he grabbed a knife and stabbed
the doctor again and then when they the
cops came said sir it's me i killed him
wow well god damn
yeah coffee to get you fired up man
oh this was crazy the last one oh [ __ ]
this is a break dancing
it's huge
no i don't think it's breakdancing
oh no
[Music]
oh damn soccer ball battle
oh
i didn't know this thing existed without
a [ __ ] hey that's actually pretty
dope that's he pulled out a red card i
had no idea this stuff even existed is
called one ball that means you have been
ejected from this when you get a [ __ ]
red card
do you remember when sedan
bring up sedan oh please red card
world cup he head butts him
is it the headbutt
bring up sedan
my favorite soccer player please let me
out of here sit down bring it up yeah
bring it up here's a cup he's a coach
though this is it dan headbutt
yeah i do headbutt maybe you have a
right card
watch this top one
the guy called him a terrorist he called
him a terrorist watch this
it wasn't supposed to end this way i
love him one of the games
the one below is just the eclipse calls
his mother a terrorist because he's
algerian
[Music]
he was such a hero
let's go back ham yeah please go back
for the love of god
and then right there there you go yeah
seven minutes this is seven minutes one
minute but if you fast forward it's just
going to show the hit
oh this is like him scoring goals and
[ __ ]
does this just highlight him scoring
goals it's so great to watch him
when he does it he just you see him talk
and he smiles and he comes back and he's
[ __ ]
well there you go
there you go i don't know if we're going
to find it i think it's right there
this
that's it kids
here's the red car dude
you're out you're out of the [ __ ]
world cup dude that's just crazy
man that's insane he got kicked out of
the world cup you guys it's crazy
yeah yeah i'm going to carry a red
carpet you see how i tried to make sure
the show's not ruined
see how i always tried to steer this
thing down the right path well i was i
was literally excited for this yeah got
it i took all the
um hey listen if you like comedy are you
tate orlando are you guys tired of your
run-of-the-mill knockout are you sick of
mickey mouse if you're tired of mickey
mouse and mickey mouse
hey guys if you thought that headbutt
was entertaining if you'll see brian
come see the headbot of comedy remember
night that's friday saturday orlando
florida the improv that's where the [ __ ]
i am kids and it's gonna be exciting i'm
in every washington with the squad 30
minutes from seattle uh one night only
theater play ever washed in november
27th then dania florida's december 30th
through january 1st
it's fort lauderdale danny of florida
come get some bring in the new years
with your thick friend here thick boy uh
authentic dodger and philly jerseys drop
friday and also the built athletic gear
that you see me rocking now also drops
on friday as well thickboy.com friday
morning 9 a.m and then tomorrow i'll be
at tacoma comedy club and then the
following night i'll be at spokane
comedy club and then december 1st
san jose improv and then also check out
chappelle's world on all podcast
platforms yes oh [ __ ] uh conspiracy to
social club on rockfin too yes.com
conspiracy social club all right love
you guys bye boom